[Music]
happy birthday to the world wide web did
you know is 30 years old this week the
web has been a force for good half of
the world are online we use it all the
time to land couldn't connect find love
and of course for a spot of shopping
however its founder Sir Tim berners-lee
has written an open letter which
highlights his concerns he's worried
about how the Internet has been used for
malicious intend and the consequences of
things like fake news outrage and
polarization
I'm width setting undoubtably the
Internet has enhanced our lives but we
live in times which are becoming more
divided by the second the Internet is a
tool which enables hair to be created
and spread one which allows bullying to
take place
24/7 and one which allows people to act
often with no fear of consequences as
with all tools it is of course how we
use them which counts and we therefore
need to make sure that we're focusing
our energies into building
accountability new laws and good ethics
into our online society fronter I think
Michele in general in the spirit and
ethos of what you said I agree with you
I think we the tables have turned and
gone are the days when if you remember
Google slogan used to be don't be evil
don't say evil whatever it was and and
everyone was full of this heady optimism
that the internet was gonna assure in
this new era of loving friendly business
and it turns out
surprise surprise hey presto they are
just another money-making machine in
particular Google Facebook and and the
other large social media companies I
also think that there is a case to be
made
perhaps with antitrust legislation that
some of them need to be broken up so for
example Rupert Murdoch and you know okay
clearly he has his own issues but he
mentioned recently that they should
bring forward legislation that splits
the advertising side from the search
engine side of Google because it's
killing publishing now if we were to put
aside a bit like Tony Blair and the EU
referendum if we were to put us out to
the side who's saying it and look at the
substance of the point there's a point
and I think actually yeah they have
become too big and too powerful and of
course the consequences of that on
weather then moderating their own
content whether they consider themselves
publishers or platforms that's where the
hate comes from because they don't
believe that they are held to the same
standard or should be held to the same
standard as newspapers and that and
thereby they're not under any of the
regulation the newspapers would be if
newspapers printed half the stuff that
is allowed on social media platforms I
mean I know that because I want a huge
defamation case against a not-for-profit
organization in America you know people
are held responsible for libel and
defamation but social media companies
aren't and yet they've got fire
magnitude of millions a larger platform
an audience through which to spread
those lies and I think the last thing
I'll say is I think the genie is already
out the bottle it's probably a bit too
late and the bigger danger now I think
is because the technology has been
invented already we can't undo that a
bit like the nuclear bomb the bigger
danger now I think then is government's
who have this technology like in China
that have created a kind of a social
credit system where they can reward or
punish you based upon your views and
whether you comply and that's where I'm
now what watching Pay Pal and other
financial services companies on the
internet have started taking editorial
judgments as to who can use their
financial services and if we end up in a
cashless society you could end up with
certain people they don't have cash
because we don't have cash anymore but
also don't have the electronic means to
make exchanges and they end up on the
margins of society and that's where
China's headed with its Social Credit
System do you think I am of the view
that we have a real structural problem I
think we've talked that this about this
before that government does not
understand tech government does not have
people who understand tech it's always
and I think if you take the view that on
tax you know government always been a
step behind when it comes to social
media tech is 10 or 20 steps behind you
know when I was a reporter raised to
interview ministers about their strategy
for dealing with things that promote
self harm on social media that deals
with automation that deals with data in
the age of massive tech they didn't they
didn't get it they didn't have people
working for them that get it so I think
that we are regulation regulators on
massively behind and
it's just not sustainable when you think
about how powerful these companies are
and will continue to be I mean yes I
think that antitrust should be maybe
have more teeth and not please need to
be broken up but I don't think that's
gonna change the fundamentals the future
is going to be run by companies that are
more powerful than nation-states and
scary that is scary but we live in a
capitalist society they've found a
business model that works what can you
do I think and I'm not saying we
shouldn't do anything I think that
government needs to massively step up
and also hope you live in a communist
society and I'm not saying we should
live in a communist society and even if
I were I would make no difference but I
also think that you know if you look at
George Orwell and only thing he got
wrong in his genius vision the only
thing he got wrong was he imagined in
the future that by coercion we would
have our privacy taken away from us he
could never have imagined that we would
willingly give it away that's what we do
get away from publishing and the sort of
capitalist structure because I think we
need to bring it back on its 30th
birthday to have the internet you know
Tim berners-lee
set him thought maybe you'll be like the
Koch and teach the world to sing in
perfect harmony and it hasn't what it's
done is it's given that a brilliant
vector or conduit for people the nut
bags out there the angry people out
there to show their anger and you know
there are we've all got to live with
that around this table Michelle you this
week in particular and our MP since
we've had but don't let's pretend that
political discourse has be has been
anything but devices divisive since the
beginning of Parliament but let's just
if I may Nick here from some female MPs
who are going to read out in honor of an
International Women's Day which has
masked tweets that they have received in
the course of their work whereas
representatives your less attractive the
medusas fugly sister naughty Caroline
notes is a self-centered
silly wee lassie how can she even talk
about saving the hospital when she
Tory scum fits into the blonds danger
Caroline Dynegy
is a worthless I might just add that you
know the Internet is also wonderful
amber Rudd gave a speech on
International Women's Day which I was
present and she said that she also had a
tweet that said um but she read it out
said amber Rudd the only reason you're
in cabinet is no you're useless you're
hopeless you've been fired from every
cover net position red the only reason
Theresa May has put you back into
cabinet is because you're so
good-looking and everyone loved it so
you know we've got to retain our senses
of humor I showed you my social media
this week your hair at Cal I've had it
all barrels this week and your neck I
want to pick up on your introduction the
thing that fascinated me most most was
the on line dating have you ever is
something I've never experienced am I
the only person in the panel today who's
never online day this is really this is
what interests me right never mind all
them no no no no it's the false
representation and you think you're
going to meet
I don't know whoever you think you're
gonna meet that the most attractive
looking man in the world you know the
star from yeah this is what I want to
know that's what I you never mind always
tell me what how he portrayed himself
and what was the reality when he turned
up in the barrio this is where and thank
you for taking my my topic way off here
absolutely not dating yes very briefly I
did go on a date a quite a while ago now
with a guy and I was in the band he was
message saying I'm here and I couldn't
get my head around where he was looking
where are you where are you so in the
end there was a guy that was on his own
and I thought it's not him and then I
rang him and I was I rang in this guy's
furna new weapon
house like it wasn't good and I said to
him because I am confident enough to do
so I said to him with all due respect
you don't look you've misrepresented
yourself massively and I doesn't match
the right foot for us to get off on so
I'm gonna
it wouldn't be the right that's what we
wanted right from Michelle's dating
disasters to deadbeat dads coming up
after the break why do women always get
the blame
[Music]